that person that goes I I love when I
hear these aphorisms and and things and
maybe it goes on the Whiteboard that's
on the front of my fridge for a couple
of months how does that person get from
mental masturbation yeah around it to
action that this this impacts my life in
a tangible way that actually makes a
difference to me any of the things that
we go through today all right two things
one is knowing the input output equation
the second is knowing what your fuel is
going to be so if you can't define the
inputs and outputs that are going to get
you what you want then there's no way to
start right because you don't know what
you're supposed to do so you have to
Define it down to like the most basic
first action so it's like if I want to
start creating content that means I have
to post something if it means I have to
start doing cold I always think in terms
of business because that's what I'm in
but like I'm either doing a cold reach
out I'm doing a cold call cold email
cold DM whatever that is I have to make
a piece of content I have to post stuff
and make a podcast I have to make a
YouTube video If I make a short whatever
that is make a blog post
um I have to run an ad right I have to I
have to run the ad I have to press go I
have to spend the money whatever it is
like whatever that core initial action
go to the gym lift the weight put the
shoes on whatever the input is you have
to Define what the input is that's going
to get you the output you want now once
you know what that input output is the
next one is why aren't you doing it
right and so I think a lot of people are
looking for something
that is very hard to find and so and
then they attribute their lack of
success or lack of action because they
don't have passion or motivation right
and I was the same way and so uh the
short story around this was that I uh I
watched all the TED talks in college
like that was like what I was like I'm
not watching YouTube I'm watching TED
talks and I was like and then I realized
and then I heard the term mental
masturbation and I was like oh that's
definitely what I've done
I was like my life hasn't changed at all
and then I got my jobs out of college
and I would read all the self-help books
like every night that's all I did I just
read all these self-help books and I
found one of them
that said there are people who are
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurs
and I remember hearing that word
entrepreneur and I was like it made me
feel sad I was like I want to be [__]
watch but I was like I'm not some [__]
like like but but I was like but what if
they're right
I am a entrepreneur I'm not an
entrepreneur I want to be one and I'm
not and from that point it took me six
months to quit my job to actually decide
to do the entrepreneurial thing and the
thing there are many things that
contributed to me being able to leave
and I think a lot of it's not like
people are looking for one thing it
might be a big bag of wise a lot of them
right that add up together to be above
your action threshold and
I think in the early days people are
looking for the big carrot they want the
big Vision they want the big passion
but they don't have it but I want to
I'll give you the first rule of
Entrepreneurship that I've learned which
is use what you have and a lot more
people have pain a lot more people have
anger a lot more people have shame and
if you can use that as your gas in the
beginning you'll eventually get to a
point where you can get out of that Loop
and then find something that you are
really passionate about but if you can't
tie your shoes you can't lift the weight
you can't send the DM then you have to
start with whatever you have and so for
me it was hatred of my current existence
I hated being an entrepreneur I hated
being a wannabe I hated being one of
those people who like talked about all
the things they were going to do and
didn't do anything
um
I hated living
the life that my dad wanted me to live I
was I was his [__] that's what it was I
was his [__] I was living his dreams
out not mine and that was you know led
to that other tweet which was um
sometimes your parents dreams have to
die in order for yours to live
and
for me I realized that the idea that my
father had of me as his son that image
had to die
in order for the image of myself that I
wanted to be to live because I kept
trying to quit my job and go be an
entrepreneur and every time I'd have the
conversation be like ah come over we'll
talk about it we'll have dinner you know
what and he'd always talk me off the
ledge it was always over and over again
good salesman yeah and or great
authoritarian uh
you don't need to persuade when you have
compliance
um and so uh and so everybody has that
person or or it might actually be
somebody who's talking off the ledge or
might should be a voice in your head
doesn't really matter because that that
voice in person that only happened once
or twice probably keeps talking to you
when you're at home
um but the big thing for me when I when
I decided to make the jump and mind you
I was such a [__] about it that I I had
to drive across the country before I
called him to tell him that I left yeah
I remember like I didn't want to yeah I
didn't want to confront him
um
which he then like flew off the handle
about
um but
I just knew and this is the Tony Robbins
quote but it's just the when the pain of
staying the same is greater than the
pain of change and I think that
I think pain moves people far far more
effectively than pleasure does like the
easy thing to wait to prove it is like
point a gun at someone's head and you
have absolute compliance and they will
do what they need to do right
automatically just like that
like death is the great motivator and
the gun just reminds you
and so I think that if you can create
the figurative gun to your head of the
pain that you're experiencing and then
I'm a big fan of future casting out
negative scenarios so people talk about
like positive visualization I prefer a
negative visualization which is what if
I keep doing what I'm currently doing
for the next 10 years will my life look
like then that usually takes my current
pain and then just magnifies it and then
that allows me to get my action
threshold high enough that it goes over
the edge so that I can take that first
move and so if you know what the inputs
outputs are of what you need to do the
guy who has the little quote on his wall
and you figure out whatever fuel you've
got not the one you wish you had but the
one you've got and you use that to do
the first input you cross the line
you're in the game
I told the story on the episode that I
did with Goggins about bullying in
school and this was something where I
like opened up about a topic I haven't
spoken about a ton because it made me
feel weak and it made me feel vulnerable
and so on and so forth
but
one of the things that's only really
recently happened and it's actually been
assisted by the guy that reached out and
messaged me this dude messaged and said
that he was sorry for what had happened
his daughter was going to school and it
reflect made him reflect on his time
um at school and how he treated me and
he was like dude I just wanted to say
that I'm sorry I don't even know if
you're going to see this I'm happy that
you seem to be happy but you know I I
just had to get it off my chest and that
really helped not that I was carrying
much yeah but one of the questions you
know you've spoken about your dad in
this kind of like authoritarian
relationship and living out that dream
how
did you
avoid or how have you got yourself to a
stage now where you're no longer driven
by a chip on your shoulder toward him
because I think that there are a lot of
people that go through challenges in
their past yeah that you find fuel in it
and they go wow I can be filled by
hatred yeah phenomenal I can alchemize
this toxic thing into something which is
useful totally
but I would imagine that that has a a
shelf span right that if you keep on
using that for long enough there are
more optimal ways that you could start
to move perpetually under your own
motion transmuted into something else
how did you get past having this chip on
your shoulder about the relationship
that you'd had with your dad and where
it had set you back or forward or
whatever
um
or have you yeah I think I have
um I think my realization was you know
first the goal was make as much as my
dad then it was make more than my dad
then it was making more than my dad had
ever made and I realized that the
approval that I had
that I saw it was always going to be
moved right I mean I've told this story
before but maybe not your audience but
like when I when I my dad and I didn't
really speak a ton you know we texted
you know two minute phone call hey
you're alive okay cool
um but for that was kind of like for
like five-ish years
um after I left home uh to go do the gym
thing and only once gym launch was like
printing money
um and so we were I think I was taking
home a million and a half a month at
like 27 or something like that and he
gave me a call out of the blue and like
my dad doesn't like cold call me
um and so I'm sitting at dinner and I
step outside
and he says um hey you're going to want
to sit down for this and I was like okay
he's like I'm sorry I was like about
what he was like
everything
and I remember in the moment actually
feeling nothing
and thinking that was curious and then
being like huh
okay
and I probably should have just like
accepted it for the Olive Branch that he
was probably trying to like lean out to
me um but here's what I said instead I
said you know how
people get up on stage when they win the
awards and they're like I just want to
thank my mom and dad for always being
there always believing me I was like I'm
not going to say that I was like because
you weren't and you didn't believe in me
and
right after that he was like well we'll
see how long it lasts
and so
it was after that phone call that I
realized that everything that I'd done
to that point was to try and beat him at
his game because everything my dad cared
about and not everything he's a good guy
like you know we're fine now but like
when I was growing up and it's fairly
common in most foreign families to be
very like money driven and I always knew
that kind of subconsciously and he would
never say this but like I felt it
because whenever he introduced somebody
he told me how much they made
immediately he'd be like this is John
John makes this like this is Bob he
makes this like it was just it was just
like the worth and the name was like
immediately tied together
and so I realized that I was trying to
win his game rather than playing my game
and I think when that happened it was
the same instance of kind of like the
blame finger but just at a different
level of saying like Okay well I don't
blame my dad anymore but I'm still
playing his game
and so I'm winning not my game I'm
winning someone else's and so I think
when I was like okay well then I have to
define the game and the meaning of the
game that I want to play I have more
responsibility now because I have to
define the rules of what matters most to
me Etc
um but that was where I feel like I got
and maybe there's more that I'll unpack
later but that was kind of the next
level at least for my awareness of how I
perceived what I was going after what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]
foreign